[Music]  first thing on  hey miss Potts if you find this  recording don't feel better about this  part of the journey use the end  [Music]  just for the record being adrift in  space with zero promise of rescue is  more fun that sounds food water went out  four days ago  oxygen I'll run out tomorrow morning  I've been when I drift off I will dream  about you  it's how I see you  [Music]  [Music]  danos did exactly what he said he was  gonna do  he wiped out 50% of all living creatures  we lost all of us  lost friends Yost family  you lost a part of ourselves  this is the fight of our lives this is  gonna work Steve I know it is cuz I  don't know what I'm gonna do if it  doesn't  hi is anyone home this is Scott Lang we  met a few years ago at the airport in  Germany that got really big is just an  old message I know you know that  that's me can you buzz me in  [Music]